نتابع هذه الصور المباشره لهبوط مركبه
الفضاء التي كانت تقل رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين ريان والجرني بعد نجاح مهمتهم
الفضائيه وكانت المركبه الفضائيه التي
تقلهما كانت قد انفصلت عن المحطه الدوليه
للفضاء تمهيدا لهبوطهما في المحيط الاطلسي
وهذه صور مباشره بعد عشره ايام من استكشاف
الفضاء واجراء التجارب الفضائيه المختلفه
في حدث حظى بمتابعه كبيره في الاوساط
السعوديه والعربيه وفي اطار برنامج هامل
للغايه تسعى بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
للدخول وبقوه الى عالم الفضاء واجراء
التجارب الخاصه به للاستفاده من
التكنولوجيا المتعلقه بالفضاء هذه صور
مباشره اذا انه نتابعها هبوط المركبه
الفضائيه في المحيط الاطلسي والتي كانت
تقل رائدي الفضاء ريان والجرني ريانا
والجيرني على مدى الايام الماضيه حاضيه
بمتابعه كبيره للغايه كان نجمين في سماء
الاعلام والمتابعه عبر وسائل الاعلام
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي المختلفه كان
هناك ترقب لكل ما يتم من خطوات خاصه بهم
خاصه خلال العشره ايام الماضيه من
اكتشاف هذه الرحله التي كانت محطه وخطوه
هامه فيما يتعلق ببرنامج
طموح للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في مجال
الفضاء
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور تتابعونها على
الهواء مباشره
لهبوط ريانه
والغرني رائده الفضاء السعوديين بعد نجاح
مهمتهم في الفضاء
وكانت الانباء السعوديه كانت اشارت الى
اختتام رائدي الفضاء ريان والقرني مهمتهما
على متن محطه الفضاء الدوليه تكون بذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قد دشنت مرحله
جديده في اكتشاف الفضاء والاستثمار في
علومه
المتخصصه طبعا هناك خطط سعوديه طموحه في
مجال استكشاف الفضاء
وبالتاكيد تعزيز مكانتها بين الدول التي
تتسابق الان نحو الفضاء بشكل كبير
بالاضافه الى سعي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من خلال هذه التجارب الى دعم
قدرتها على اجراء ابحاثها الخاصه بشكل
مستقل
رائده الفضاء ريان
والجرني كان قد ودعا محطه الفضاء الدوليه
على متن المركبه الفضائيه عائدين الى
الارض بعد تحقيقهما مستهدفات المهمه
العلميه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه والتي
تسعى من خلالها
للاسهام في الابحاث العلميه التي بتاكيد
تخدم البشريه عبر تجارب مختلفه للعديد من
الدول بالاضافه الى محاوله الاستفاده من
الفرص الواعده التي يقدمها قطاع الفضاء
وصناعته عالميا وبناء القدرات الوطنيه في
مجال الرحلات الماهوله كانت هذه الرحله
بصحبه طاقم مهمه اي اكس 2 والتي كانت تضم
رائدي فضاء اخرين كان يصحبان ريان والجرني
في هذه الرحله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات